the european union is in
permanent contact with the rest of the world in
the european parliament
forty and a delegation of deputies
maintains its relations with their
counterparts throughout the world this
in fact organizes parliamentary diplomacy
with either partner states
or regions each  of
these assemblies that we have a
specific number of deputies that represents the
equivalent number of members of
parliament with the same number of
parliamentarians who come from partner countries
it depends on what type of delegations
you are for some cpc in the agreement
of  cotonou it is well institutionalized
in these African European countries possible
there are two plenary parliamentary sessions
where the joint regulations
are complete and you then have
regional meetings
for other delegations
it works a lot on the invitation
it  is to say that there are countries for
which today the priority
to go and see on the spot was  t on board
have made resolutions have made
resolutions with vote resolutions
without screws religions with debate without
debate exactly like the
european parliament like classic parliaments
function there is a report
so first the subject and chose itself in
function whether it is an important subject
for both countries whether it is about the
fight against terrorism whether we are talking
about migration whether we are also talking
about the environment we decide on the subject and
at the moment there are two co-rapporteurs
who are appointed they work
together to present a report which
is debated in the economic
committee political committee under the
human rights committee go there so we follow
all the files really very closely
every word outside that you
say weighs most of the  media
will not specify that you are a
parliamentarian coming from such countries they
will say the european union says the
european parliament has
a mega phonic power which is
colossal
in the  no president likes to be criticized
by the european parliament